pierre Tanguay Poliquin et mécanicien ce
qui se trouve sous le capot n'a pas de
secret pour lui
mais quand vient le temps de démêler le
fonctionnement de l'Agence du revenu
c'est plus compliqué parce que la main
gauche parle pas la main droite je sais
que c'est que beaucoup de gens qui
travaillent là durant la pandémie pierre
a reçu par erreur un chèque de PCU il a
renvoyé au gouvernement sans même
l'encaisser à faire régler pas tout à
fait un jour je reçois par la poste une
lettre disant que je dois 2000$ encore
pour la CPU que ça a été remboursé ça
peut être payé donc j'étais un petit peu
stressé sur le coup je suis quand même
ok qu'est-ce qui se passe et tu le sais
que tu étais perdu pour Pierre et sa
conjointe c'est le début de deux ans de
confusion bureaucratique
le gouvernement confirme avoir reçu son
chèque mais continue à lui envoyer
lettre par dessus l'être pour lui
réclamer le même 2000 dollars déjà payés
ça cause un stress parce que on taille
aussi longtemps que on reçoit des avis
puis que c'est comme si il y a quelqu'un
qui pensent qu'on doit encore de
l'argent pierre et Geneviève ne sont pas
seuls dans cette situation après
vérification le gouvernement reconnaît
l'existence d'une confusion la PCI fût
est mise à la fois par l'Agence du
revenu et par Service Canada les
particuliers doivent donc toujours
s'assurer d'envoyer leur remboursement
au ministère qui a émis la prestation
c'est ça c'est ils mettent la faute sur
les citoyens c'est inacceptables des
centaines de gens se plaignent à leur
députés de vivre ce calvaire j'ai envoyé
2000 mais on me réclame encore de
l'argent
et les gens sont inquiets et c'est
clairement une indication de de chaos
chez le gouvernement mais maintenant il
y a des échanges informations François
Boileau est le défenseur des
contribuables selon lui un tel chaos
n'aurait pas dû se produit et le
gouvernement doit faire mieux pour
simplifier la vie des gens que la
communication ne semble pas se faire de
façon efficace et ça des conséquences
pour pour les citoyens
la ministre responsable reconnaît le
problème mais n'offre aucune solution
concrète ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on veut
que
ces cas sont bien réglées et on va faire
l'enquête
pierre et Geneviève s'impatiente
au milieu de cette partie de ping-pong
bureaucratique qui dure depuis deux ans
je dis qu'est-ce que je fais
présentement attendez c'est toujours la
même réponse attendez
une attente dans l'inquiétude pour leur
code de crédit et dans la crainte de la
visite erronée d'un huissier ici
Christian Noël Radio-Canada Gatineau